(crowd cheering)
- Have y'all ever met before?
- No, but um-
- We got chance to chop it up in the back.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- And he told me he was
gonna let me reenact the
scene that he was showing me.
- That's right, yeah.
I wanna show him some stunts.
- I know, I'm like, man.
- Can I tell you something?
I've only ever been to
one basketball game.
And I saw this man.
- Oh really?
That's the one that you- yeah.
- Yeah, the one basketball
game was Knicks, Heat
and you guys won.
- Yeah, well.
- Yeah, well- how we do.
That's how we do.
- It had nothing to do
with me being there.
- I think you were the good luck star.
- I'm gonna take some credit.
- He has no talent over there.
Oh, but no.
Were you into sports growing up though?
- Yeah, I, soccer.
- Like, So you're football?
- Football, yeah.
- Yes. You're football, yes.
- Football.
But yeah, I just did a translation, but.
- I know you were being nice.
- All my friends are gonna be like,
what are you talking about?
- I know, I know.
America, we just took
the name and ran with it
with a different sport.
- Yeah, it's a completely different game.
- You're welcome.
- I like it.
- Yeah, but I, it's a,
that's a hard one though.
That's a lot of cardio, soccer.
Did you ever play?
- I did, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I played every single day.
That's what I did.
- Oh yeah?
- Every lunch break, in the
morning, in the evening.
Yeah, I was obsessed.
- Oh my god, don't you wish--
- But I wasn't an athlete.
- Well...
- You know,
that's why my dream didn't come true.
- What?
Wait, wait, if you-
- You know, you have
to work so hard and uh.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] You do, but wait,
if you're playing everyday.
- And I did-
- If I'm playing every day,
I'm calling myself an athlete.
That's what, that's
what I'm calling myself.
Wait, so, okay, so wait,
was there anything you ever grew up doing
that you loved but you weren't good at?
- Yes.
- Okay, we wanna hear that
'cause you're so excellent at basketball.
What did you suck at Dwayne?
- Singing.
- [Kelly] Oh, singing?
Oh, now I wanna do a Kellyoke with you.
- Me too.
- Yeah, every day.
Terrible at it, every day.
- In the shower, everywhere.
- Everywhere.
- Well, your daughter can
sing, so she got it...
- Well, not from me.
- [Kelly] Okay, all right.
- Mama, that's mama.
- [Kelly] All right.